hi everyone thank you so much for
joining us I'm joined here by Sarah
Carmichael from Bloomberg's opinion desk
Sarah thank you for making the time I
just want to start by asking how you're
holding up and how you're doing thank
you for asking I am doing well I feel
very lucky to be isolating with a
husband who loves to cook so I feel very
fortunate that is true yeah I'm good I'm
good it's nice for both of us that we
are out of the city and we have some
outdoor space so we are very lucky to
have that I want to introduce ourselves
to the audience real quick my name is
Madison Mills I'm a reporter with
Bloomberg joined here by Sarah
Carmichael who recently wrote about
working from home and what our future of
remote work could look like for folks
watching please comment with any
questions you have for Sarah and I will
ask as many as I can I want to start off
by just doing an overview of this piece
you just wrote can you talk our audience
through some of your thoughts on working
from home more permanently yeah so
recently a number of companies many of
them in the tech industry have decided
to just say that people can work from
home indefinitely or permanently or
until the end of the year there's been
some kind of long term plan made and
this is an interesting development to me
in part because I think one thing it
gives employees is a sense of certainty
which we have had so little of during
this time it's kind of a way of saying
you know we can craft a new normal
together we're not just at the mercy of
events and it's also a way of giving
people perhaps more flexibility and and
for a lot of people something they may
have wanted for a long time so I see it
as a very positive development overall
although there's clearly it's not
without its challenges which I'm sure
we'll get to right that's such a great
point Sarah we see over and over that
people would much prefer to work from
home particularly in these open offices
that are very popular right now I'm
wondering why more companies aren't
committing to that full pledge to have
people work remotely it's a really big
change I mean there is a real culture of
FaceTime and I think a lot of bosses
have been very anxious about work from
home arrangements
I think that one thing that this crisis
has forced people to confront is that
people can work from home and be
productive at home so some of the early
data we're seeing suggests that people
are actually putting in more hours at
home which holds true with data that we
had collected on people who work
remotely before the pandemics so I think
bosses who are maybe skeptical or coming
around and that's another reason why I
think you see people gravitating towards
this as not just a short-term sort of
crisis solution but as a potentially
long-term solution right and you
mentioned that it's nice to just have
that kind of certainty right now when so
much is up in the air do you think that
more companies will at least commit to a
certain month that people might expect
to return to work or what do you see the
upcoming trends of these announcements
looking like I sort of see three
distinct approaches one is work from
home it definitely this is just what
we're doing now this is a permanent
thing then there's on the other extreme
there's this kind of you know come back
as soon as possible we're gonna revisit
this every two weeks kind of rolling
approach and then there's something in
between where some companies are
basically taking it quarter by quarter
and saying okay you know it's almost
June we're probably gonna be doing this
till September so you know and that's a
kind of way to kind of balance both
approaches because I think for some
bosses and some jobs working remotely is
really not possible and it's really
about the kind of work you do so if you
are in the knowledge transfer business
and you're on a laptop all day then
probably working from home was going
fine but if you're in a different
industry where a face-to-face contact is
more important then those are the
companies that are gonna want to find a
way to get back sooner absolutely and
can you talk us through some of those
industries that might just not be able
to work from home and what their options
might look like yeah so I think a lot of
them are the service jobs right I mean
you cannot give someone a haircut
remotely you cannot clean someone's
teeth remotely so there are things that
are at all you know all kinds of
different jobs that are going to
acquire some kind of in-person contact
the jobs where you can work from home
tend to be information based technology
based maybe you're a consultant who
mostly does research and even if you
were used to traveling four days a week
before maybe you've now realized that in
fact you don't need to be doing that so
I think this is forcing us to confront a
lot of hard truths and assumptions we've
had for a long time about the value of
FaceTime and about whether you really
need to be present in person to do the
work or not right right and you've
talked a lot about the value of FaceTime
I think something that people are
questioning right now is job growth
right at the moment of the pandemic it
feels like people are okay with delaying
discussions about salary raises or job
growth or things like that but if we're
working from home for years to come
people are gonna want to have those
conversations right so when do you think
that moment will shift where people
start to feel comfortable talking about
their career trajectory from home right
I think that's a really great question
and so I have a couple different takes
on this the really optimistic take is
that this will be a great way to cut out
a lot of the kind of politicking and
image-conscious
maneuvering in the office where you get
ahead not by producing a superior work
product but my thing with the right
people and you know coming in early and
staying late and just appearing to
always be working which I don't think is
healthy and which doesn't usually
correlate with actual performance
outcomes so in a sense if this shifts us
towards a way of recognizing merit that
is really based more on what someone
produces and not how they seem then I
think it could have a really positive
outcome for people who do great work but
who maybe aren't the most vocal and
meetings or who don't hang around the
water cooler looking to kiss up to the
boss right so that's the optimistic take
the pessimistic take is that there are
gonna be new kinds of schmoozing and
politicking that come out of this you
know maybe you think okay every Tuesday
I randomly send an email to my boss
telling him or her what I worked on this
week cuz my work is just not as visible
if I'm not in the office so there
are gonna need to be new ways that we
promote our work but I do think
especially in companies that are healthy
I mean races and promotions are still
definitely possible and do I hear you
correctly there that there's not
necessarily a correlation to your output
and the hours you spend at the office
can you talk about that a bit more yeah
this is one of those research findings
that has been borne out again and again
and again and which I love because
basically it means most managers right
default to judging what's easy to
observe which is how quickly someone
recite replaced you an email or how
often they see them in the office do
they see them [ __ ] quick through the
office with this has a purpose but
actually if you look at performance
reviews there is not really managers
can't really tell who is working long
hours and who is only pretending to work
long hours so there are some people who
pretend to work long hours through sort
of moves and chicanery but who are not
actually sort of putting in as much time
as they seem to be so managers have a
really hard time distinguishing that
which to me suggests that in fact
superior performance is not the same
thing as working all the time and we
know from cognitive studies that if you
work all the time your performance
actually decline well that is a study
that I can get back to thank you for
sharing that I want to go to some
audience questions that we got in
overnight here we have one question from
a user who asked if I want to work from
home permanently should I expect to pay
cut and I think this is something you
also want to talk about with Facebook's
announcement from last week but I'm
wondering if you can just respond to
that question yeah I think it really
depends on the company and the industry
and I think you know ideally in a
perfect world companies are paying
people for the value of the work they
provide and you know that shouldn't
change that much if you are working from
home and some for some people it might
go up in fact you might provide more
value if you are able to concentrate
better and aren't interrupted all the
time by colleagues so I think that it's
gonna really depend on conversations
with
individual managers and bosses now
Facebook very interestingly said
basically people who take advantage of
the work from home new work from home
policy to move out of the very expensive
California neighborhood where Facebook
is located will get a pay cut and I have
to say on the one hand I guess good for
Facebook for being transparent about
that on the other hand it's a very sort
of strange announcement and that um it
was sort of accompanied by this comment
that anyone who takes who tries to hide
where they're working to avoid a pay cut
will be severely punished which it was
like okay so you're setting up from the
beginning that you don't really trust
your employees which is very strange in
a remote work environment especially
where Trust is really important and then
also a pay cut is you know human beings
have an instinctive reaction to having
things taken away from them we don't
like it we might be willing to forego a
bonus but if you actually take something
away and claw back our pay we get very
upset about it so if I were a company I
would look more to maybe other or perks
and and ways to proceed without an
actual pay cut because people do notice
that absolutely and you mentioned this
Facebook announcement we have a quick
sound bite from mark we want to air
really quickly so let's just take a
quick listen to that over the next five
to ten years about 50% of our people
could be working remotely but we're
gonna do this in a way that is measured
and thoughtful and responsible so I'm
wondering if you can just talk through
what impetus Facebook or other companies
would have to keep people in these
cities if they're moving to a permanent
work-from-home model yeah so I think
that it's really interesting to see this
play out in the tech sector because it
does seem partly motivated there by a
desire to get some of these salaries
under control I think I was reading that
the median salary at Facebook is in the
mid $200,000 a year range so that's the
median salary right so people who are
working there are making a lot and
that's a huge cost for Facebook so I
think that there there are you know
things people want to do maybe there to
try to control those costs
and then there are also issues with
office space so I'm sure that there may
be have space issues they wouldn't want
to try it to control those costs as well
so I think that um you know one of the
funny things about Facebook saying
outright that they're gonna cut people's
pay if they move away is that it might
have this strange effect of keeping
people coming into the office it's like
oh well if you were gonna cut my pay if
I moved then I guess I'll come in after
all so they were hoping to use that then
they might have just undercut that a
little bit right and you would imagine
that it would discourage people from
doing that if they were thinking about
it and I wonder if you can also talk
through how the relationship between an
employee and manager might change if we
forever work from home that's a question
we got from our audience yeah so I think
that this is really a fascinating time
to be a manager a challenging time but
also a time when there are so many new
habits and practices that we can try and
I think the important thing to remember
is that our old way of working wasn't
ideal either so even if your onion two
problems with remote work there were
probably also managerial challenges you
had when everyone was present it's just
that we have different challenges out so
like something that seems to be working
very well is regular check-ins so maybe
you just touch base with employees over
the phone at a scheduled time every week
and maybe it's not for very long maybe
it's just for a few minutes but that
kind of replaces a casual walk by
conversation where you might have once
just drop by their desk so they're there
does need to be a little bit more
intentionality I think and how bosses
are communicating with employees and the
other thing that you know is is it sort
of interesting in this moment too is
that I think that there's a sort of
desire by managers to use video calls as
much as possible
but it turns out that the boss employee
relationship is inherently a power a
relationship in which power is different
right and so what we're on video with
our boss we might be thinking too much
about how do I look right now and what
is my boss saying to me and should I
look into the camera or should I look
down at their face you know and so I
think actually for these check-ins a
phone call
probably better than a video call just
because it'll gently relax a little bit
more that's a great point that's really
interesting feedback and I wonder you've
talked a bit about the end of water
cooler discussions right what will a
world of working from home look like not
just for the manager employee
relationship but for peer-to-peer
relationships as well yeah I think it
will be different right it's um there
are some tools like slack where some
people may be introverts feel actually
more comfortable being themselves in
that kind of environment where they have
time to plan out what they're gonna say
and so there's still these informal
conversations happening but it's
sometimes it's different people chiming
in so I think and some people are gonna
love it it's gonna free them up to maybe
be a little bit more share a little bit
more with their their colleagues and
they would have other people who are
used to hanging out by the water cooler
might find it a very challenging
transition so I think we need to be
sensitive to that especially when we're
sort of negotiating new relationships
with colleagues and I think that this is
another place where you know video
meetings tend to start right on time
you're not walking around looking for
the room right so you can just sort of
start as soon as you all sign in and
then people have a tendency to get right
down to brass tacks from the outset but
maybe spend a couple minutes at the
beginning just chit-chatting to replace
the sort of lack of natural chitchat
ability that we have during the rest of
the workday right I so appreciate your
optimism through all this it's such a
great point that introverts might
actually thrive in a work from home
environment that's a really lovely point
Phenix I mean I'm a little bit
introverted myself so I I do find
sometimes it's I am more comfortable on
slack or email than I am just sort of
like roaming the office looking for
excuses to talk to people so O'Brien
I'll feel the same way I'm sure they do
and I also I want to ask you going back
a little bit to this discussion about
Facebook and working from home things
like that do you think that offices will
start to let go of their leases in these
expensive places particularly in New
York City where the rent is so
astronomical yeah I think some companies
especially those who
to aggressively cut costs that certainly
is one of the places that they will look
it can be very expensive to break a
lease but if your lease was expiring
anyway maybe you'll decide to move out
of that expensive neighborhood but that
was so easy to commute to like right
downtown maybe you'll decide to take a
smaller space to take up fewer floors in
the building
if people stopped coming into the office
as much but I actually see this as a
sort of positive development in some
ways because I think office space is
expensive it's a major cost for
companies and they may just find that
it's cheaper to let people work from
home for an indefinite period of time
than it is to try to retrofit their
office with you know an air filtration
system or some kind of new Plexiglas
barrier to protect people from getting
the virus that way so for a lot of
companies just sort of reducing their
footprint is going to be a better option
absolutely and more broadly you see
employees I know I can speak for the
Millennials of New York that rent is
very expensive and without needing to be
there for our jobs there's not a ton of
reason to be there other than social
life which is also gone so do you see
people leaving these big expensive
cities to kind of have a bit of normalcy
right now that's a tough question to
answer because anecdotally yes I have
heard from many friends who you know we
live in the suburbs as we have many
friends who live in the city who are
suddenly very interested in what our
life is like in the suburbs before they
sort of dismissed us as being uncool and
now they're like oh maybe that's nice
but I think that moving is a really big
decision and for a very long time
economists have wondered you know why
don't Americans move out of struggling
cities into cities where there are more
jobs Americans just it's especially
Americans don't seem to move around that
much according to economic sort of
nudges the decision of where to live is
highly personal no matter what at the
end of this New York is still gonna be
New York so I think it is one of those
things where right now there's a ton of
headlines about this is you know the
death of cities and the rise of suburbs
and I adjust them a little bit cautious
I don't think the changes will be that
extreme
absolutely and that also leads to
another question we have on commuting do
you think that if if people don't leave
these big cities where commuting is a
challenge do you think commutes will
change at all I would love to see them
change because most of us really do not
enjoy our commutes that much I think
what we might see as things get to a new
normal is people going into the office
every other week or people going in some
days of the week and not others I think
that you know that would certainly have
a net positive effect for many people's
lives having that flexibility it would
have a net positive effect on the
environment if there's fewer of us
traveling every day just to do in an
office the exact same thing we can do at
home so I think there will be a change
in in commuting I think one of my sort
of fears is that virus worries will have
more people wanting to commute by car
and fewer people wanting to take public
transportation so that obviously will
lead to huge crowding issues parking
issues and environmental issues so
that's another reason why I think
working from home at least part of the
time is a great option of course and you
mentioned this earlier as well but we
got a lot of questions from our audience
about if they want to work from home
permanently should they expect a pay cut
and and you've talked about how
employees can actually be more valuable
from home but I'm wondering if you can
give some advice for how employees might
broach those conversations I would not
be the one who brings up the pay cut I
would talk to your boss about permanent
work from home or indefinite work from
home or medium term work from home
arrangements but never be the one to
raise the pay cut issue do not ask your
but like don't plant that seed in their
mind I think a lot of managers are
receptive to suggestions that you
approach as experiments if you say you
know wow this last couple months of
working from home I have just been so
productive I've gotten all this stuff
done be specific point to your
accomplishments say I would love to be
able to continue this for the next three
months and see how that goes I think a
lot of managers would be receptive to
that and responsive to that and then
maybe at the end of that period of time
you can say you know could we do this
keep trying this maybe another six
months let me know if you ever perceive
a problem with my work happy to come in
if you need me to come in but this seems
to be working well for everyone if you
are able to make that kind of case and
point to results that show that you're
being super productive then I think a
lot of managers would be happy to grant
you that but never be the one to say oh
and I would take a pay cut you know to
be able to do that just just don't don't
ever offer to give money back to your
company unless they unless they bring it
up first very good advice there and I
also want to remind our audience for
those watching please comment with any
questions you have for Sarah and we
won't get to as many as we can here one
topic we haven't touched on is working
from home for parents what is a working
parent supposed to do right now and and
what will they do if this becomes
permanent this is a really tough time
for working parents and for people who
have caregiving responsibilities I think
especially with young children who are
less self-sufficient and you know who
may not understand exactly why you're
staring at your laptop all day this is
really tough it's especially tough for
single parents you know a lot of work
from home were arranged Minh cyno are
ones where there's two parents in the
household and one parent sort of works a
morning shift where they you know maybe
they work from 5:00 in the morning until
noon but then their spouse works from
noon until you know 7 p.m. and then they
just trade off who takes care of the
kids if you are a single parent though
that option is obviously not available
to you so I think that again one of the
things this virus is forcing us to do is
confront like what services are truly
necessary and I think schools child care
these things are truly necessary so I
think that to the extent that we can
reopen parts of society that need to be
reopened but keep those parts of society
closed where in person contact isn't
necessary I think that's a way to keep
the curve fairly flat it's not like a
switch where we reopen everything you
know reopen school go back to the office
go get a haircut all at the same time
you know if a third of the US workforce
from home they should keep working from
home but we do need to find some kind of
sustainable solution for parents because
this is just not sustainable for them
right and you also wrote in your piece
about things like internet access which
is not equal for everyone can you talk
about those problems a little bit yeah I
think one of the challenges that this
time has been met as we've individually
encountered these challenges whether
it's Internet access or you know child
responsibilities we're all solving them
as individuals and what companies can
help do is come up with solutions that
work for a larger proportion of their
staff so for example on the Internet
access issue if my internet access is
bad there is very little that I can do
as an individual to improve it I can
sign up for faster bandwidths but I you
know I'm limited by where I live so I
think that something companies could do
for example is switch to some systems
that require less of that bandwidth so
video calls are very bandwidth heavy and
it may be that you need to have some
video calls but you can do the rest over
the phone and then it's less of an issue
so I think there just needs to be some
sensitivity to the fact that not
everyone has the greatest internet
connection and what are the solutions
that are a little bit lighter weight
that companies and teams can use that
don't look quite so much pressure on
them wonderful point and we have one
other question from our audience who a
member who asked instead of working from
home well companies consider staggering
work hours or rotating days you talked
about this a bit but you know what
systems companies are already talking
about implementing yes so I think one of
the solutions I've seen companies using
is asking basically breaking their
workforce into kind of an a team or a B
team or a red and blue team and having
one subset of workers come in for two
weeks then they clean the office they
disinfect everything maybe they have a
weekend in the middle to let any germs
died natural deaths and then the other
team comes in for two weeks and they
kind of alternate that way that seems to
be working reasonably well I think it's
better to do something like that and say
have people alternate days because then
you know that's a lot of cleaning and
well we've got a lot of companies to
have beefed up their cleaning it seems
like it's better to go maybe like one
week and then another week as opposed to
having sort of every other day and then
in terms of hours a lot of companies are
also doing this for people who do need
to come into the office so you don't
want everyone sort of pushing into the
elevator at the same time at 8:30 in the
morning so maybe you ask some people to
come in at 7:30 and some people not till
10:00 and you just kind of space it out
that way throughout the day absolutely
and we have to let you go here soon so
that you can get back to your amazing
work but we did have one audience member
comment that this is a once in a
lifetime possibility for for climate
change to potentially be positively
impacted by this moment where we're all
working from home but I know you also
mentioned that people might be in their
cars more how do you see working from
home implement or impacting our
environment I am so glad that you raised
that question because to me yes I want
100% agree if we can make this work from
home work and come up with the
management systems and processes we need
to really support people as they make
this transition it could have a huge
impact on the planet and I think that um
you know one of the things that's gonna
be really challenging and fearful for
people in the future is public transit
in the immediate future so I was very
happy to be a trained commuter I felt so
virtuous that I was taking the train
instead of driving but I don't really
want to do that hour long train ride now
with a bunch of people who could
potentially be sick so I think that to
the extent that companies can support
people and work from home arrangements
for the indefinite future they could
have a really important impact on the
planet and on the mission so I really
hope that is a factor that companies are
considering absolutely so we're so
thankful for your time
just as we're wrapping up here is there
anything that we didn't talk about that
you think is important to add to this
conversation anything that's been on
your mind about working from home I
would just say I understand that there
are some jobs that are really tough to
do at home but what we know from Census
Bureau data
that a third of us probably can do our
jobs from home and if we keep staying
home as even if sometimes it feels a
little weird and even if we miss our
colleagues which I do it will make the
world a little less dense if that makes
sense for the other people who have to
move around and go in so I think that if
it's working for you if it's working for
your company it's just something we
should keep doing a little bit longer
until we learn more about this virus and
the direction it's going to take and
maybe beyond that - for environmental
reasons absolutely with Sarah thank you
so so much for joining us we're so
thankful for your time and thank you to
our audience for watching you can follow
a quick take on all platforms we're on
Twitter Instagram Facebook YouTube so be
sure to check us out and thank you so so
much again thank you this was great